c'est au tour d'alexander montoya
d'encourager d'autres étudiants à
apprendre le français mais il faut pour
phase de test
il fait maintenant des études
supérieures en mathématiques mais a eu
de l'aide en arrivant de colombie grâce
au jumelage interculturel
oui comme on entend à chaque session
l'école de langue de l'uqam associer un
étudiant francophone est un nouvel
arrivant
alexander il a appris plus que le
français parce qu'elle m'a expliqué
comment faire quoi faire et quoi
parfaire depuis quatre ans ses jumeaux
se donne des nouvelles de temps en temps
c'est ça qui se fient à fait pour moi ne
fait comprendre la société d'accueil
il faut pas dire que c'était juste me
qui apprenaient moi j'ai appris beaucoup
de choses
on pense qu'après de 12 mai
jumeaux qui se sont rencontrés il ya
énormément d'étudiants qui participent
chaque année la personne immigrante être
en contact avec un francophone qui
parlent le français depuis toujours donc
est beaucoup beaucoup de l'apprentissage
que ça fasse un tel impact sur la
motivation à apprendre le français tout
le monde bénéficient de ce programme qui
fait tomber des préjugés de part et
d'autre au collège vanier
l'enseignante philippe gagné a commencé
à faire des jumelages avec des cégeps
francophones pour sortir ces étudiants
de leur bulle anglophone à la hausse pro
forma
c'est comme ça que nicolas a rencontré
danic au lieu de les prendre comme un
projet pour moi j'ai pris comme une
opportunité de faire un ami alors mon
oral s'est amélioré beaucoup nos jeunes
arrivent et un bon tiers d'entre eux
résistent à l'apprentissage du français
parce que les deux solitudes n'ont pas
disparu tant que ça plus nos étudiants
anglophones ont des amis francophones
plus il parle en français avec eux
chaque semaine plus la motivation
augmente plus l'attitude envers le
français parlé au québec est positive
l'uqam et le collège vanier viennent de
créer un groupe de recherche sur les
jumelage interculturel
une formule qui peut favoriser non
seulement l'apprentissage d'une langue
mais aussi de l'ouverture à l'autre ici
anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal